[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 61 of
the weekly google app from podcast hi
I'm Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark modèle hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks francisc all
the better because we're in the same
room at the same time finally for not
the long but finally we're a little bit
a little bit just a week but that but
yeah finally back from Europe and still
not in India so there you go San
Francisco yeah and we have a very
interesting episode that I mean I'm
excited about it but I know that you're
even more excited cuz you know video
games I seem to be very excited a lot
lately I've noticed it seems to be a
recurring thing you're always excited
you're always excited about this episode
lady I be having pretty cool episodes
and actually the two next episode that
we're gonna be having we already know
where they are and they're also very
exciting they're also very exciting yes
so this week we have rub Whitehead a CTO
at improbable joining us improbable is a
company that helps you build massively
online persistent worlds and so we're
going to chat with them they run on gcp
it's a pretty cool partnership we also
have with them so we're gonna talk all
about that yeah very interesting
conversation talking about how to
basically help what you do it if you had
to build the matrix kinda kinda yeah
yeah a very very interesting
conversation but for sure and I want to
be the architect though I get to be I
get to be the architect you don't really
have that beard though that's true yeah
sorry oh yeah sorry no that's okay if we
were to have an architect we know we
know who that will will be and he works
at Google that's true a soldier anyway
at the end we'll have the question of
the week which is about resizing disks
um something you know pretty normal and
not that exciting but you might need to
do it at some point and knowing this may
make your life so much easier definitely
but before that we're gonna go with our
cool things of the week and they're
seriously cool they are seriously cool I
know the first one you had a fair bit of
involvement in let's see that Google
Cloud endpoints is now generally
available yep we had GA
and it is pretty amazing it dad's
actually the topic i'm going to be
talking about doing my club neck stock
in 2-3 weeks yep so so yeah i think that
the most interesting like the cool thing
about Cloud endpoints is the fact that
it allows you to do many things that you
need to do but without any effort which
as Managing like you know you need to do
log in you need to do monitoring unit
authentication you need to do all of
those things we've glad endpoints you
get to do all of those but just having a
swagger spec or open api specification
which is friggin awesome yeah it's it's
in the kelsey Hightower scale of
dopeness is pretty dope so it is it is a
very cool thing to have check it out it
is now GA and there's a bunch of things
that it does it is supported on GCE on
gke on App Engine for java and python
and actually anywhere else you can run
it anywhere we have a small and gnex
proxy that you can run anywhere cool
yeah so pretty cool that's very cool now
the second cool thing of the week is
super cool yeah i mean it is it is
globally it is what's the word globally
consistently cool look what like that it
is a globally consistently cool thing of
the week yeah we released cloud spanner
which is our spanner product as a
service yeah so the public beta for
cloud spanner I globally distributed
relational database service yeah it is I
mean it is pretty amazing because if you
think about it it's basically like we
had already an episode on BigTable
mm-hmm and big table is kind of a big
deal I see spanner like as an evolution
of a big table because you're basically
providing things that normally you only
have in relational databases yep but
globally distributed and consistently
and available which you know it is kind
of crazy yeah so like you have all your
traditional like sequel stuff so you see
cool you've got schemas you've got
consistency that's great but you've also
got really high availability horizontal
scaling basically up the
wazoo yeah like to a global level and
automatic replication and like global
transactions and consistency it's pretty
crazy we're going to definitely do a
whole podcast topic on it but yeah there
is a couple of blog posts that you can
read about it right definitely deserves
a full episode if it's not more than one
but for those that might have cringed
when I said that it is a it is both
consistent and globally available that
is good to cringe we have an article
explaining why it is not really true but
almost you enough it is true enough it
is not completely available but the
availability is so high that it is
basically globally available so we have
a bunch of links in the show notes so
you can read that cap theorem white
paper on spanner but there's also a
bunch of all the ones that you may be
interested by there's also a bunch of
different tutorials that you can try
there's one for go how cool which is
pretty nice but also no tears and I
think Java and whatever you want to do
so go have a look play with it it is
pretty amazing it is indeed cool so why
don't we go have a chat with rob at
improbable then let's oh that sounds
good today we are joined by a very
special guest I think they're always
very special guests but a very special
guest rub Whitehead CTO of improbable
Rob how are you doing today yeah no bad
mark are you doing very very well thank
you so much for joining us coming to
talk to us about improbable about
spatial OS before we get stuck into that
why don't you tell us a little bit about
who you are and what you do yeah sure so
I'm Robin co-founder and CTO of a tech
company called improbable were based in
London about 150 of us previously I kind
of like sort of i started probable fresh
out of college in 2012 for I kind of met
my co-founder Herman in Cambridge and
yeah like sort of my roles evolved in
the years from working on core
technology to now kind of like sort of
looking after how the product which I'll
you know we'll talk more about spatial
OS is being specifically applied in the
games industry cool so uh to be honest
for me was the first time i heard
improbable
but improbable was when I read a
headline same thing saying something
that improbable teams with google and I
actually didn't realize it was a company
name saying I had some hard time farce
in the sentence could you tell us it of
it for people that the know what like
people that are not like mark into video
games I'm not what is improbable why is
it important what do you do yeah sure
and so it's probably worth like sort of
telling a little bit about this kind of
story behind you where we got to spatial
OS and in the early days are kind of
like hang out with them and we we had
this dream for a kind of a truly living
world video game whereby you know except
of traditional games are kind of
constrained either in terms of their
scale or in terms of the fidelity of the
world so you'll get kind of very large
open world games which very limited
interaction we get kind of very very
like to lavaca smaller like sort of more
high fidelity wells like a game like
kind of battlefield and we wanted to
build a game that was a truly living
world where they were kind of millions
of like sort of trees and millions of
kind of like sort of animals monsters
and the the players themselves were
completely incidental inside that world
and it had huge amounts of physical
fidelity and we knew kind of in every
scene games like that before and we kind
of knew that you know this necessary
would require us to come up with a way
of having multiple computers in the
cloud cooperate together to simulate the
same space because the world is going to
be too rich and too large for a single
machine chopper deal with and you know
as we kind of evolved removed from our
kind of le prototypical ideas of
building a game into kind of building
this foundational simulation platform
which is kind of what we're doing now
cool so all right so you've built this
platform called spatial OS what can you
do inside of it like is it just games or
what's what's the possibilities special
OS is a platform for building simulated
worlds so what I mean by that and any
problem you have which involves a set of
entities which are things and they
interacting kind of unexpected in
complex ways and the the scale of those
interactions and they kind of fidelity
these interactions is so so large that
you want to be using like the power of
multiple machines spatial as nails so
you know just if you're kind of trying
to like similarly a very huge game world
then you're going to have you know lots
of player entity
you have monsters trees inventory items
if you similar thing a city those
entities might be cars Road segments
traffic signals pedestrians buildings
and it really depends on what Dominion
modeling and the kind of gal be like
that are formal about it we it's kind of
in the realm of kind of complex systems
modeling its modeling systems where you
have lots of buildings interacting and
then you get kind of crazy emergent
consequences from that awesome alright
so this is the google cloud platform
podcast usually we talk about how i use
google cloud platform but as well as
that i think it's worth noting there's a
partnership here between google cloud
platform and improbable as well do you
want to talk a bit about how that works
and what that provides for developers
yeah so um you know sort of I think like
both problem you will agree that Lena
specialist lets people kind of you know
build fundamental new kinds of game
experience with these kind of massive
simulated meaningful worlds but also
that smaller teams do so and the idea of
our kind of games innovation program is
about like sort of enabling like sort of
game developers do you get credits to
start developing the spatial of us
thanks it for free and I think sort of
essential you have credits so that
rather than you know when you're
developing your game you have to kind of
pay for the compute getting used to you
have pay for the compute after lunch so
it's kind of like sort of helping you
kind of get up and running and like sort
of not be afraid of really pushing the
boundaries in terms of what you can do
sweet so gcp is partnering with you to
help power that that whole program yeah
yeah exactly perfect and if people are
interested in the program or they want
to build something on specialist for
that program is there any information or
upcoming or available right now yes so
we're going to be announcing the
specifics of the program closer towards
GDC but right now like said anybody who
kind of like sort of signs up through
space was calm will be eligible to kind
of apply for the program and so if
anyone's interested in kind of going
through that I'd recommend they go to
spatial s calm and go through those
steps cool so I wanted to note it a bit
about how like you said that there's the
name of the OS spatial OS is it really
an OS what does it look to be a
developer and to build something on top
of it yes oh I mean that says that's a
very good question so speacial OS is a
kind of classes at distributed operating
so when you kind of have traditional
operating systems you know android
windows they will own a single machine
and spatial OS is kind of a layer above
that which lets you take multiple
computers and kind of consider them to
be one big computer and kind of presents
an abstraction on top of that so
specifically spatial OS runs on top of
core LS or on a cluster of machines in
the cloud and then gives you api's you
can treat it as kind of almost one big
supercomputer nice so it kind of sounds
like it's like a video game specific
Cooper nannies almost all right yeah i
guess like sort of the the core
abstraction is you kind of look at you
know traditional well it's a platform as
a service and you kind of look at kind
of traditional platforms as a service we
had the early days we had like sort of
tools like kind of Google App Engine
which are about kind of a stateless web
application with some persistent data
back end and that was great for a
certain group of people you know if you
want to build like sort of certain kinds
of mobile backend or you want to build
like sort of a web app you can just nail
that out really fast and and then you
kind of had sort of more flexible
platforms like Google Cloud functions
with let you kind of have these like
transient pieces of computation acting
you know responding to things like a cut
pub/sub us and from from our side we
found that wasn't really a kind of a
platform with an abstraction that was
really about kind of creating these
large-scale simulated environments and
spatial Wes we kind of felt like a fill
that in and so rather than thinking
about your kind of you know your poster
machines is a set of a you know a bag of
containers like like with Cuba Nettie's
you think about your question machines
is a three-dimensional space it's kind
of a pretty crazy abstraction but it
actually works so you think of your
cluster has a huge kind of three
dimensional space and inside of it you
put entities and those entities are the
things I talked about before you know in
your city simulation they're your
vehicle's your roads your traffic
signals in your video game their players
monsters Lutz you're all that kind of
stuff and then under the hood were kind
of you know partitioning up the data and
computation of that world across a
cluster behind the scenes for you so
okay so if I'm a developer who wants to
build something on spatial OS what does
that development flow look like I think
you mentioned maybe their command line
tools or like how does how do I build
something from start to finish with
Salek an engine like maybe unity or
something else yeah for sure and so it's
worth saying you know
from from our side we really believe in
kind of people taking the tools already
familiar with the kind of use our
technology so let's say you're kind of
traditionally used to building like a
dedicated server base multiplayer game
in unity you'd have a you know unity
dedicated server pro rebuilt out Linux
running and you probably put on some
either dedicated machine or on some vm
and you tell some clients go and connect
to that and so with with spatial arrests
you kind of download our SDK which is
just a series of command line tools and
like sort of and web web UI is
essentially and you kind of get plugins
which actually tie into whatever game
engine you're using so whether you're
using Unreal you're using unity or
you're using kind of your own game
engine this essentially handles your
connection into spatial OS and handles
kind of you know taking the part of the
world which your your kind of engine is
simulating and synchronizing it with
with the broader world and yeah you
pretty much like have business as usual
so like sort of once you fill your
application using kind of your your kind
of game engine of choice you build it
out into what we call an assembly which
is almost like a distributed executable
it's the kind of this application which
you're going to kind of push into our
platform and it's going to run across
lots of machines and from that you just
use a single CLI command just like
spatial deployed and it takes your kind
of built our unity application and
pushes it into our platform and then it
carves out those VMs and that cluster
behind the scenes and then instantly
you've got a kind of a simulated world
running their kind of up in the cloud
and the next step is you know you can
take a URL for that and share with a
friend and have both you login cool but
does that mean I have to write in like
some sort of custom language or doing my
escaping my usual set of tools or how
does that work no so you can use like
sort of your existing set of tools be a
you know unity unreal whatever game
engine or whatever kind of tool you want
to be using for that the the thing which
kind of binds us all together and then
they kind of magic is traditionally like
sort of worlds would be built around
from having a single kind of dedicated
server running in the cloud now there's
a cluster of machines so completely for
a game like worlds of drift we're
actually running hundreds of instances
of a game engine like unity in the cloud
cooperating together to simulate a world
much bigger than any single kind of you
know one of those engines could ever
understand and then plugging into the
world as well you can have you know like
said well over a thousand clients
interacting in the same physical
environment and again that's kind of
much larger than you know a single game
you could ever deal with and that's
because spatial OS is this distributed
cluster handling the you know in memory
persistence of all those entities as
they mutate handling the kind of like
sort of network fan out of you kind of
like you know moving around the world
and having all the things you're seeing
streamed in G so going on on the
developer experience of special special
ways and curious about if MapReduce the
hello world of MapReduce is counting
words what is the hello world of spatial
OS so if you go toward github you'll
find there's actually an example kind of
game simulation we call hello world and
it really is kind of try and demonstrate
the kind of core aspects of kind of what
the technology does so hello well there
is am I guess we kind of clean this term
mm / which is kind of I don't know if as
good as I catch on with this idea kind
of like the this hello world project has
two teams and the two teams are running
at each other and these little wizards
and they kind of start with very small
amounts of our characters and they kind
of build up and up and up until they
were kind of thousands aside kind of
like sort of attacking each other and
the cloud deployment has two inches of
unity overlapping and co simulating to
simulate the entire space so it's kind
of a good example of something showing
you know a interesting like sort of game
environment with kind of emergent
complexity and interesting gameplay
mechanics it's got the two workers
cooperating together demonstrating that
you know spatial s is letting you use
more than one more than one machine and
yeah like that's like the kind of
foundational thing you tend to jump off
from nice I've played it there's lots of
fire it's fun yeah marks mark set me on
fire wasn't very wasn't very friendly
okay so friends are for cool all right
so now I'm also curious rights with
specialist sounds great platforms of
service for these massively online games
why does special Western improbable use
Google cloud platform like what do you
what are you using on us as products
yeah sure so like sort of although as a
developer you can interact with spatial
OS under the hood with the kind of
innovation program like so we we run on
Google compute engine to actually like
sort of our run those those VMs so like
sort of when you create a space less
deployment you'll get me using like sort
of a Google VMS to kind of
get requisitioned and start and this
kind of a the thing we found with with a
Google vams is specifically around kind
of the provisioning time so excited here
a small group of you know indie devs and
you try and do a game jam and you want
to be iterating rapidly and you know
pushing your simulation to the cloud
like sort of having like a type
provisioning loop is really good because
the amount of time you go from a CLI
command to actually having a game
running in the cloud you can go and play
and when we found kind of GCU is kind of
like sort of specifically good for that
and the other side which is kind of
something to bear in mind with games is
a lot of the the web is kind of built
around TCP as built around these kind of
request response connections a lot of
JSON and when you kind of likes it a
move towards applications like games
you're actually dealing with fire hoses
of unreliable UDP packets and
traditionally like it a lot of clouds
haven't really been set up to kind of be
particularly good at routing that kind
of traffic and like sort of them from
our side we found like sort of a Google
cloud platform was a good choice in
terms of like games networking is all
nice so I think that on top of using
google cloud platform you might have
also been using other Google open source
projects like you mentioned caress and
Caro as they say I think their headline
is something like Google and frustration
for everyone are you using something
like gipc or and yeah there's this
actually plenty of stuff to talk about
and the the first thing yeah is grp see
although the kind of the core entity
synchronization things within all type
of kind of bespoke the the platform
itself in terms you know requisitioning
deployments getting metadata all that we
kind of use grp see and the reason why
we like that is kind of you know one is
very very easy like streaming responses
based upon HTTP to and the the other
side as well as kind of a you know
having that kind of binary serialization
by default and also having a typed RPC
system by default as well rather than
throwing around JSON and we found it was
kind of perfect for our use cases and I
guess it kind of other thing in the cool
space for users basil and so we kind of
have a when you're building a simulation
platform you're building api's which can
either be used in c-sharp c++ JavaScript
Java and a tool like basil lets you kind
of handle them on
repo which has like a load of different
like sort of languages kind of working
together in the same build and so we
found that in valuable in terms of like
Oh scaling as an engineering
organization so it's actually
interesting normally when I hear people
using this many tools from a Google open
source world especially they're normally
ex Googlers durand I excuse though right
so are a few people from our kind of
infrastructure team RX Googlers and
there's a certain like that a bit of bit
of that in there we have a kind of a
good cross-section of different people
and attack like spatial OS you can in
turn this weird blend of we kind of have
the the kind of X large-scale software
companies to kind of give that kind of
you know production and scale kind of
stuff you've got people from high
frequency trading firms so it used that
kind of really low latency high
throughput kind of interactions I know
people from the gaming industry who are
kind of around all the kind of tricks
and all the skills which go into kind of
building a very efficient game engine
for example so I guess well the next
question is are you hiring haha yes we
are I'm so we actually have offices in
you know is in San Francisco we just set
up recently though we also have all kind
of our home base in faringdon in London
I'm so this kind of you know we have a
lot of us hanging out there oh yeah
we're kind of always looking for kind of
you know in people who are interested in
this kind of thing in terms of building
large-scale reliable infrastructure and
simulating the world or building the
matrix wonderful so a curious though
like so you're building that seems like
almost a very different type of platform
from what people have built before what
were some interesting challenges you've
faced when building special OS yeah I'm
we had many many like challenges on our
quest as definitely definitely worth
saying and some kind of like sort of fun
stories to talk about that and one is
kind of when you start running like
normally a game it will kind of run with
a single server binary kind of running
in the cloud and occasionally will crash
you know like said this stuff is high
performance C++ code and you know
sometimes it's going to have issues yeah
so traditionally when you run a run a
single dedicated server you'll find that
like sort of uh it's written high
performance see the first code and
occasionally in my crush but what
happens when you run a hundred instances
or a thousand instances of that kind of
that kind of game server code at the
same time as a kind of swarm of micro
services I'm statistically speaking the
we'll see if any one of them failing
goes up and up so we are kind of to bake
into the coral platform the fact that
these workers can fail and how that
works is we actually have the in-memory
representation of the world so every
entity every you know player rock
character has an in-memory
representation within the spatial
aspirin time of their state and these
workers are kind of almost streaming
processes there there that they're kind
of pulling in the data of the world
around it computing on like sort of
simulating parts of the world is
trimming that back into space for less
so at a moment's notice if any of those
kind of like workers were to fail we can
you know rush in and actually replace
them with another worker who can be
given that information to continue
computation so it's kind of one really
kind of fun problem well I say fun in
retrospect obviously they were
incredibly tough things together so I
guess I won the most interesting
challenges we had to solve is the fact
that physics engines when you run a
single instance of them they'll actually
use non determinism and how they solve
their physics to actually increase the
numerical stability of the result if you
can imagine big pile of boxes kind of
being simulated by kind of like sort of
these the algorithms inside of them by
randomly shuffling the order which those
things are processed you end up with a
kind of fellow result mathematically but
when you start to have a thousand
instances of those physics engines
overlapping and cooperating together you
get these really fun scenarios where
you'll have overlap regions and what
kind of the both of them are interest in
the same world and they might actually
simulate slightly different responses
and so from that side we had to produce
that kind of strategies and algorithms
for essentially blending their truths
together after a certain amount of time
and like sort of that's was a really
interesting challenge well now we can
actually have a stack of pile of boxes
on top of each other whilst migrating
the authority of those boxes between two
physics engines multiple times a second
and the physics simulation is still
stable so that's kind of a the way kind
of we think about is almost eventually
consistent physical simulation and I
said that was kind of something we kind
of invested a lot of effort in in the
kind of early years my head's exploding
yeah I could see is that too is that you
crazy correct yeah I'm just thinking
about it like that does make sense yeah
like it makes yeah yeah but like yep
then under typo I've got another I've
got another little chickee like some
bite thing I
say which is about the line of dominoes
exactly my favorite one to kind of
describe the technology ya going yep I
guess I guess kind of one of these the
easiest ways to kind of break down
spatial of us into his moves based
example is a game which we're not
planning on making but let's call it
Domino simulator 2017 so Domino
simulator 2017 there are 1 million
dominoes and you can flick the Domino
Ike sit on the right side and have a
cascade cascade and eventually he'll
knock over the Domino on the far left
side and a million down imagine you
wanted to simulate that in real time and
have you know people able to kind of
participate and see that the the issue
is a single physics engine wouldn't be
able to simulate the physics of a
million dominoes at the same time but we
probably have physics engines that could
simulate maybe 1,000 10,000 dominoes at
the same time so let's say you know we
actually bring up a thousand physics
engines all kind of you know next to
each other to simulate that entire set
of a million dominoes are you getting an
issue where you know when you flick the
Domino on the far right and it starts
getting down you get to the point where
it needs to kind of interact with the
next the next physics engine and the
this kind of a very very difficult
problem and the way it works is you can
think of every every entity every Domino
in the simulation to have almost a a
bubble around it imagine that a bubble
of kinda you know maybe like half a
meter in real life times and that
represents the you can think about if i
was to simulate the physics for that
single Domino how what are the things
could actually act on that at any point
in time to affect it well maybe the
Domino is very very nearby it but the
Domino kind of a million dominoes away
might eventually affect it but it's not
going to instantaneously affect it and
this idea of kind of bubbles of
simulation and synchronizing the right
data to the right physics engines at the
right point in time is a lot of kind of
what the kind of cool hard technical
problems of specialist or about that is
pretty cool so we're talking a little
bit before about the hello world and
like what are the basics the basic
things that you can build with spatial
OS what about the other the other side
of things what is the biggest game you
know that has been built with special s
interesting so I can talk about games
the other thing I kind of want to talk
about is like sativa some of the kind of
more like geographically explosive
things are in our kind of non games
applications oh yeah so it's been
specifically
one example is where somebody kind of
came in for a week to jam with us and
their knowledge and kind of Internet
network routing so essentially that the
border gateway protocol which is kind of
how all that kind of like so trim nose
in the internet kind of find out how to
read to each other and they kind of
simulated like sort of every single node
just like kind of 45,000 outs in the
entire internet and could have a
real-time simulation of how those nodes
reacted to failure so you could be like
what happens if I pull out this plow
cable how are the internet react and how
will I kind of move around its kind of
its routing of internet traffic and that
kind of thing was like really exciting
seeing you know a small group of people
come in they model kind of you know some
interactions between two entities of the
well-known like sort of set of
interactions and then they could like
scalar up to this massive scale and I
think looks sort of the one of the fun
things about like BGP is every single
node has to know about every single
other node and have a route to it and so
you kind of get this really fun like you
know there's n this kind of like sort of
every single node has every other nodes
routing information in it so it kind of
grows with very very fun comput 8am like
memory complexity so it was interesting
seeing how much memory we have to
consume to actually do that so that
sounds super interesting do you have any
like numbers you could share in terms of
how big or small that was there like how
many entities we're being like used
inside that simulation yeah so like sort
of on without internet simulations it's
kind of more about the the MCS
themselves being very heavy weight and
doing a lot of kind of algorithmic
complexity there are kind of like sort
of other simulations in our kind of City
simulation space which are in the order
of tens of millions of entities in some
xena representing buildings roads
traffic segments you know vehicles
pedestrians which are kind of pretty
exciting and then in terms of our gaming
applications or a kind of games like
walls of drift which are using you know
millions of of entities interacting
there and they they represent kind of
you know either from a tree which you
can shop and it will physically fall
over and break into pieces to creatures
that fly around and they kind of you
know mate with each other and have a
real kind of like sort of ecology around
them two players building ships out of
physical pots so you can build like a
floating skyship out of hundreds of
different panels and engines and guns
and different pieces and every single
one of those things is an entity which
is persistent so if you crash into
another ship and while those panels
falls over and lands on the ground that
lets you persist indefinitely
because it's stored in size specializes
in memory representation which again is
regularly snapshot it out so you know
even if kind of someone come goes away
and comes back again later he'll still
be there because rather than having the
transient state inside of these game
engines is actually in a persistent
layer on top awesome alright so we're
slowly running out of time where can
people go if people want to go to events
or things like that what are coming
events or appearances are you are going
to be up yes I think so if I'm it's a
big couple of weeks for us I think be
the first stop is I said GDC and so
we're going to be kind of xav go to
spatial esscom /g DC and this is gonna
be telling us all about the events for
running that we're gonna be running some
panels we're going to be doing a couple
of like tuna on stage presentations and
we also have a booth like sort of a
nearby Google cloud platform actually um
we can come and find us we're getting
putting on some evening events which you
can find out more through that link and
after that the week after is going to be
gcp next and we're going to be kind of
hanging out there I know Herman our CEOs
doing a talk I'm going to be on safe
lemak talking about some more spatial OS
just give me a good fun and yeah that's
what we like sort of the next kind of
things aren't all radar for events so I
have one more question that I need to
ask before we finish the interview which
is why is the company called improbable
oh that's a really good story that I did
I don't see where I can go with this and
so actually the if you look at our kind
of legal incorporation status the the
name is improbable worlds and I remember
as kind of we hired a very very edgy
design agency and they were hanging out
with us and remember the last thing they
said to us so like you know drop the
worlds and then kind of worked out in a
kind of quite enigmatic fashion so yeah
I guess like sort of the the other side
is like it really kind of has come to
reflect a lot of the values we have as a
company really about kind of you know
trying to do things that have been done
before and felt specifically these kind
of large-scale simulations so something
we like it's a movie no kind of arrow is
definitely cool though awesome well Rob
thank you so much for joining us we
really appreciate you taking the time
and it's been a great conversation no
it's like very much thank you so thanks
so much to rob for such an interesting
interview I learned a lot and i gotta
say that after talking so much about Oh
the kind of simulations you can do you
can you can do I want to try it yeah
it's really really really cool tech and
I'm loads of fun to work with getting
huge amounts of things interacting with
each other it produces really
interesting behaviors and like weird
stuff happens in its one ya like I don't
even want to build that game I just want
to build a little simulation you know
like like the late the game of life yeah
or like buzzers yeah I just want to
build something that sounds super cool
uh maybe maybe during my trips who knows
uh but before we finish with the podcast
we have our question of the week yeah so
well I'll ask the question of the week
so in Google cloud platform we have
these things called persistent disks we
know Lee mount those on virtual machines
so that you can write files to them and
like put data in them and a lot of sort
of fun stuff sometimes disks fill up and
that tends to be bad yeah so one option
is to delete stuff of disk which you may
or may not want to do the other option
is just make the disk bigger yes or add
more disk or add more discs that way but
let's go with let's go with making a
disk bigger I think that's just easier
is there a way I can make a disk bigger
while not having to like take down my
machine or turn it off or do anything
like that so uh this is actually very
interesting because we like I think that
the first time I have this question was
doing a training gcp 100 training and I
thought the answer was well you know you
can't create a snapshot of the disk then
create a new disk that is bigger based
on that snapshot so you have the same
data and then swap the disks that
doesn't sound like fun I mean it is
doable but it turns out that I was wrong
all right now I am wrong in any case
because there's a way easier way to do
it which is you just go to the console
and then you click on edit on the disk
and you resize it no matter if it's
attached to an instance or not you can
actually do this which is kind of an
amazing thing to do and then the second
part that you need to do is you actually
need to let the the OS that you're
running on that instance realize that
the disk change its size so you may need
to change the size of so for instance if
you doing
linux i think there's a command called
resize to FD something I think that's
right back this poly and you can follow
you can follow a the documentation for
that one because resides 2ft something
might not be the actual accurate name
but basically that's what you need to do
you first resize it from the console on
that is independent for whatever system
you might be running and then according
to the system you need to do you need to
resize that partition and that's it so
you basically are able to resize any
disk with zero downtime except if that
disk is a root disk if it is a red disk
then you still need to go through that
all the process that I was talking about
where you create first a snapshot of
tears and then you currently disk based
on that snapshot so you can still do it
it's a little bit harder now which can I
make sense cuz rude discs are root the
actual and they have the operating
system on them and other fun things yeah
so you know it is it is a little bit
more complicated to handle with but yeah
it is I think it is a simple thing and
you know it's so simple that sometimes
you don't think about the fact that you
can just click on edit and change things
while they're running and everything
just works it's fine everything's fine
wonderful all right well Fran Cesc are
you doing anything interesting you
sitting around some more I know you like
I never really interesting things never
do interesting things so I'm actually so
today's Wednesday which means that
tomorrow thursday i will be speaking at
go SF yes for the gold one that ate
release party lots of really cool things
coming on with go on the rate so we're
going to be talking about those I'm
specifically going to be talking about
context that go context but there will
be other talks about the different
topics that are new to the new release
then the week after that I will go to go
freak on India which will be in pune
which by the way we received an email
saying that it is actually pronounced
pune so thank you so much I knowing that
if we actually got more than one yes so
thank you so much I now I know it's
pronounced pune so for example that and
then i'll be a couple days in mumbai
trying to organize an event in there
then I'm coming back for club next and
then I'm living again for go free cone
China in Shanghai and I'm very excited
about that one move yes that sounds good
I don't trouble what about you what
about me so i will be at Game Developers
Conference I'll be everywhere just
everywhere I'm just I think that's going
to be everywhere we are hosting the
Google developer day i'll be doing a
sponsor talk at first thing wednesday
morning for for google cloud i'll be
doing a lightning talk on the on the
developer day as well we were also
sponsoring a variety of events around
the conference including like women in
games and cosmic games and things like
that it's going to be loads and loads
and loads of fun after that yes i'll be
at next as well we'll both be it next
good doing our podcasting and doing some
talks strangely enough fun with improper
ball myself once we're done with that it
looks like i might be doing some stuff
with vancouver in vancouver i need to
travel up there for some stuff but we'll
wait and see what's happening there but
after that i'm doing a little east coast
or i'll be doing the east coast game
conference that'll be the 18th of april
and then right after that i'll be
traveling up to the vector conference in
kentucky on the 21st nice sounds like
lots of fun with me lots of fun cool um
i guess it's time to finish but before
we finish we have not done this in quite
a while so let's go through all our
different ways of people contacting us
sure so we have twitter at gcp podcast
and google+ at plus GC podcast and we
have a web page gcp ford cars com with
an email at hello GCB podcast at hello
20 hello gcp [ __ ] hello at this is but
this thing that works there configure it
and then we are also I'm reddit / r /
DCP podcast and finally we are on slack
the hash podcast channel on the Google
cloud platform community slack which can
be found on bit ly / gcp slack wow wow
what a mouthful there we go great and
yeah let's send us your questions your
your messages telling us if we're
misspelling things like misspelling this
pronouncing we probably misspell things
but you cannot tell him so yeah and also
if you have
any ideas for episodes we are always
looking forward to your comments
absolutely yeah and if you want to come
on the podcast you know feel free to
reach out absolutely so anyway thank you
so much again for an incredible episode
yes and thank you very much to everyone
for listening and see you all next week
yep
you